[musique]
Je suis un migrant de Donetsk
J'ai quitté Donetsk en 2014 avec
le début d'événements désagréables pour tout le monde
connus de cette époque n'ont jamais été là
c'est-à-dire ce qui se passe maintenant
s'est passé il n'y a pas si longtemps à Kyiv
faire le tour j'ai déjà vu à Donetsk
Et
m'a inspiré m'a donné de l'espoir
que j'ai déjà perdu en général
en général, tout en bas, pour ainsi dire
état émotionnel
alors je suis venu ici et je suis allongé ici
pendant quatre jours presque c'est tout moi
satisfait très confortable très gentil
comprendre le personnel
[musique]
dis donc il y a tellement et quelque part la moitié
patients qui, mais ce ne sera pas
ce sera probablement la spécialité du cou
alors oh résumé ceci qui était assis
le code du sous-sol sera le fossé du corps Komi là-bas
à partir de quelques semaines par mois tel
et puis ils le transforment en sous-sol
à la base de la rovka, puis ils viennent à Kiev
où, eh bien, pour ainsi dire, les jours où l'on perd sa place
résidence et maintenant ils sont dans une nouvelle ville
en fait plus courbé car toujours en retrait
nouveau mais je pense que ce programme est pour moi
aider à renforcer et
améliorer votre état émotionnel
parce que ben ben pourquoi encore une fois
peur mais pas de raison
[musique]